Antoine Fuqua and Denzel Washington
reunite for the final entry in The
Equalizer Trilogy bringing the
franchise's violent action and
captivating vigilante to a new setting
so what happens to Robert McCall at the
end of equalizer 3. in the third film
Robert is nearly on his deathbed after
getting a bullet to the back during a
secret mission in Sicily however he
saved by a local doctor named Enzo and
stays in a small Sicilian Village while
he recovers there Robert grows fond of
the village and its people which leaves
him wondering if he could find peace
here unfortunately Robert is unable to
stay out of a tense situation that
unfolds as a local Crime Boss named
Vincent continually strikes fear over
the town so Robert attempts to protect
the people he's come to love and Destroy
Vincent's drug Empire The Equalizer 3
sees Robert face one of his most vicious
and Powerful foes yet while dealing with
his own personal demons Robert is at his
most human in the final franchise
installment coming to grips with his own
actions while also attempting to protect
this new community he's become a part of
not to mention there's plenty of brutal
action that'll leave audiences shaken
with the equalizer 3 likely being
Washington's last appearance in this
franchise let's delve into the film's
ending and see where Robert's story ends
Robert attempts to enlist the help of a
CIA agent named Emma to break up
Vincent's Empire unfortunately Emma ends
up in the hospital due to Vincent's
corrupt power and reach being so
widespread so Robert is forced to act on
his own whatever it is you and your
friends do do it somewhere else you
warning me I'm preparing after slaying
Vincent's brother Marco Vincent is
furious with Robert and comes to the
village for some Swift Vengeance he
threatens to kill the locals unless
Robert gives himself up leading to
Robert coming out of the Shadows to face
him although Robert scenes outmatched
he's joined by the locals in standing
against Vincent Enzo shoots at Vincent
while everyone else pulls out their
phones to record the situation with
Vincent not wanting his actions to be
public he says that this conflict
between him and Robert isn't over and
Robert agrees kicking off a gruesome
final stretch
the tensions between Vincent and Robert
reach a point where a final
confrontation is inevitable Vincent and
his men are shown concocting a plan but
Robert ends up striking first he makes
his way to Vincent's mansion and picks
off each of Vincent's guards one by one
holding nothing back eventually Robert
Slaughters all events its men leaving
Vincent on his own after tying Vincent
up Robert feeds him his own drugs with
Vincent's time dwindling by the second
Robert decides to untie Vincent and let
him run away Robert is with him every
step of the way though acting as his
haunting Shadow meanwhile the people of
the village are having a religious
procession through the streets which
could possibly be interpreted as them
asking for forgiveness for Robert's
actions or it could be a sign of thanks
to God for bringing Robert to them
either way Robert continues to follow
Vincent until he's lying nearly dead in
the streets
shortly after Robert leaves Vincent for
dead on the streets Emma receives
congratulations for her work in breaking
up Vincent's drug operation his corrupt
Empire has finally been brought down
meaning that the streets will be a
little bit safer Emma even gets a visit
from Robert who tells her why he became
involved in this situation in the first
place it turns out that Robert was in
Sicily on his own personal mission
attempting to retrieve stolen pension
money for a man he met while driving for
Lyft he never intended on getting
involved in something bigger nor
expected to find anything more Sinister
than Petty thieves however this
experience has made him find a deeper
sense of purpose that's allowed him to
finally find some peace there is just
one question remaining though you don't
want to play games with me just having
my teeth what made Robert specifically
call Emma for this case well it turns
out that Emma is actually the daughter
of his former colleague Susan Plummer so
Robert knew that he could trust her the
Boost to Emma's career is a way for
Robert to help Susan's family long after
her death sometime later Emma is seen
giving the pension money back to the man
Robert mentioned Robert meanwhile gets
to reside in the community that gave him
purpose putting his old life behind him
Robert has been a vengeful Force
throughout the equalizer franchise but
his Arc in this third film is about his
personal journey toward a more peaceful
life despite him still being an
unmatched fighter and merciless killer
he's brought back to reality when he's
unexpectedly shot Robert has rarely been
so caught off guard or close to death
before and the shock of it nearly causes
him to take his own life however once
Enzo starts to heal him and takes him
into his small village Robert is given
much needed Clarity and purpose the
kindness he sees in this town
legitimately leaves a big impact for the
first time in a while he finds peace and
acceptance which allows him to feel like
he belongs in this place because of
these people I'm beginning to understand
real peace however he's still concerned
about falling into old patterns when
Vincent arrives uncharacteristically
Robert initially stands aside so as not
to ruin this quaint Paradise there's an
internal conflict within Robert that has
him questioning his purpose within this
community and whether he can act without
being seen as being a violent man like
Vincent eventually though Robert
understands that acting is better than
standing by While others he's grown to
love get hurt his action ultimately
allows him to be seen as a protector so
despite Robert being forced to act with
Force he's still able to be accepted by
the community
when Enzo first gets Robert in his care
he asks if he's a good man or a bad man
Robert replies that he doesn't know and
while that answer might scare some
people it actually Comforts Enzo in a
later conversation Enzo mentions that
Robert saying he doesn't know if he's
really good or bad anymore actually
proves to him that he's good he believes
that good men don't simply Proclaim that
they're good and that their actions
speak far louder this plays into a
deeper aspect of Robert's Arc throughout
the franchise as a vigilante Robert has
always sort of watched the line between
good and evil despite there being good
intentions behind Robert's actions he
generally spares no mercy on his foes
leading to some horrifically bloody and
brutal kills so when this good or bad
question is posed to him his answer is
fitting especially given that he's in
sort of a personal crisis when it's
asked Robert has always resided in a
sort of moral gray area but with it now
being directly posed to him viewers get
a better sense of what his morality
means to him by the end Robert has given
the Fresh Start he felt he could never
find which allows him to put his bad
past behind him and move forward as a
better man
while The Equalizer 3 is a very personal
look into Robert's perspective on his
own morality and lifestyle it also shows
how powerful a sense of community can be
before being brought into this town
Robert was mostly just a loner trying to
instill his own sense of justice under
wrong doers however once Robert starts
getting to know the people of the town
he sees something he hasn't seen in a
long time people interacting with one
another with genuine care and living as
a community even when Vincent does
something horrible the people all band
together to help one another recover
Robert's been stuck in such a dark and
violent world for so long that he's
almost forgotten that he too can live in
a peaceful place like this it shows how
meaningful being a part of a
positive-minded community can be and how
a kind-hearted culture can legitimately
change someone The Good Vibes of these
people rub off on Robert in a big way
which is why he's willing to put himself
In Harm's Way to protect them Robert's
experience in The Equalizer 3 is a
reminder of how a good sense of
community and togetherness can warm the
coldest of hearts
within the film's depiction of community
there's also a strong sense of how
people can go from bystanders to taking
a meaningful part and making change
happen when Robert first arrives in this
town he sees that the people while
incredibly kind and genuine with one
another live in fear of Vincent and his
men they're often intimidated by
Vincent's violent tactics particularly
how public and grisly his kills are even
when one of their own is physically
attacked or beaten they don't act
outside of just helping them heal
despite this community having the
numbers against Vincent and his crew
they've been heavily outmatched by the
Firepower and sheer viciousness of their
opposition however as much as this
community has inspired Robert to have a
better perspective on his life he has
also inspired them in a way when Robert
is about to sacrifice himself to keep
Vincent from killing the townspeople not
only does Enzo step in to keep Robert
safe but the other civilians take out
their phones to record Vincent's actions
it's a moment where these people step
out of their bystander status and take
effective action together for the first
time
both Fuqua and Washington have stated
that the equalizer 3 ends the trilogy
and that this will likely be the last
time these two work in this franchise in
an exclusive interview with Looper Fuqua
mentioned how sad it was to be leaving
The Equalizer franchise behind well
that's like a breakup there was a moment
I was sitting there watching it on the
big screen I thought oh man I'm saying
goodbye to Robert McCall I don't want to
do that but
everything comes to an end in an
interview with Empire Washington
expressed the same mixed feelings about
bidding farewell to McCall saying I
don't want to give it all away but he
meets someone lovely he's in a lovely
town and he seems to be at peace that
seems to be a good place to stop
obviously someone else can come and
direct a new entry or maybe a spin-off
focusing on Emma since it seems like her
story is just starting however that's
probably not happening at least for a
while so fans can expect this to be the
last time Robert McCall will be on the
big screen at least with Washington
playing him
or maybe there's a way to bring the hero
of the series back after all while there
hasn't been any talk of a sequel to The
Equalizer 3 to continue Robert's story
there have been some interesting
conversations about a potential prequel
in an interview with nme Fuqua mentioned
some interest in a prequel film in which
Washington would return but be de-aged
digitally when discussing the potential
of de-aging AI Tech Fuqua said that he
considered using de-aging Tech in The
Equalizer 3 and that he's had
conversations with franchise writer
Richard wink about it de-aging AI isn't
the only way that Fuqua sees a prequel
happening though that's not a
conversation I've ever had with Denzel
you know and I'd have to have that
conversation with Denzel and obviously
the studio in an interview with Joe Blow
Fuqua also brought up potential actors
to portray a younger Robert McCall Fuqua
mentioned that he'd be interested in
seeing Michael B Jordan playing a
younger version of Robert and was a big
fan of the interviewer suggesting the
name of John David Washington Denzel's
son who has starred in films including
tenet and Beckett at the moment there's
no still prequel in production but the
options are out there it seems Fuqua is
willing to return for one so it could
happen
foreign